every week we put together a little
guide of great stuff for you to watch
read see follow do and listen to over
the weekend
first up somewhere to visit if you like
natural beauty and cracking open a cold
one
we've got the perfect thing for you to
do this weekend go to mklobeultra.com
and fill out an application to be their
chief exploration officer because the
beer this is serious
i mean this is real by the way wait
until you hear the story
you're going to want to sign up the beer
brand if i didn't have my dream job i'd
be signing up
um but i'm so lucky uh the beer brand
wants to pay someone to travel
the country's beautiful national parks
and snap pics
and rep their brewskis along the way it
pays 50
000 for six months of work
plus gas and expenses transportation
obviously thank goodness
is provided a sweet camper with its own
shower and bathroom but the bigger
takeaway
honestly no matter what is
i'm a lifelong rv enthusiast i've driven
around this great country
my entire life and they've done this
mapped out
markings of all these states and its
landmarks
and i have to tell you you got to check
it out if for no other reason to get
great suggestions and ideas of places to
hit it's really comprehensive
okay like i'm a map collector and i've
driven around the country and i was
really impressed with this list
next what to watch time for a movie this
weekend
opening at our drive-in movie and here's
to watch
the broken hearts gallery it's a story
about a young woman who turns her
heartbreak into an
art installation for everyone to see wow
take a look there are broken people out
there like me
people who need to let go and move on is
this the heartbreaking you're in the
right place welcome
are you ready to hand it over it has an
odor
we're in business baby it looks great
and i think it's a really fresh concept
and it stars the sweet and funny
geraldine vispana
sun from blockers let me try that again
geraldine this one often i only
practiced that seven
times too that's what's so maddening
about that
she's from blockers and miracle workers
and she's like
all the rage and it's a really great
rom-com treat for the weekend
next step time to hit follow a good
follow is
food 52 on instagram
if you enjoy drooling over fresh pastas
and many other food you are going to
love this account
they also post amazing user-friendly
recipes and videos you can get so
lost in them they're eight minutes long
it's perfect
new chefs that they recommend and their
kitchen tools
i'm telling you this is the place to
shop if you're an enthusiast
all right next download one second
every day it's an app that takes one
second from all your videos in your
library and cuts together
a little movie for you out of all of
them and i fall in love with this app a
little more
every time they send me another little
montage of my life
it's so beautiful and finally one last
thing
i want to recommend magnolia bakery
their banana pudding
they have released this recipe and
they're world
famous for this banana pudding and
people are going
bananas and they're shipping this
pudding all over the place i'm telling
you it's crazy
magnolia was first made famous when
carrie and miranda ate cupcakes from
magnolia bakery on that sex and the city
episode
you know ever since moving to new york
myself i've wanted to become a real
manhattanite
like carrie bradshaw i couldn't help but
wonder
what would it feel like to walk just
like carrie
and be in one of her manolos for a day
so
i did
[Music]
you